so i've got the wrong meeting chat
and welcome to this northwestern area
planning
planning committee meeting on wednesday
the 29th of july 2020.
hi my name is council and this is madly
thompson i'm the chairman of this
community
the meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april in response to the
kovit 19 pandemic
these are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
first of all can i please ask everyone
present in the meeting to ensure your
microphone is muted and your video feed
off when you're not actually addressing
the committee
this reduces background noise and avoids
any unintentional disturbances
the meeting is being hosted remotely
strained live and recorded and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
you're reminding that apart from that or
if you have to leave the meeting the
chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
please do not use it says
we're saying please do not use the raise
hand function as this is not available
on all member devices but
if you would like to use that please use
the chat as well
when speaking and referring to agenda
papers please ensure you reference a
page or paragraph number
could i also ensure that everyone is
directed to
connect directly connected to a power
supply so nobody drops out due to a shot
of short battery life
and last of all if members need to leave
the meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function to signify that you need
to leave and
also repeat return please may i ask
members
officers now taking part in the meeting
to introduce themselves
can we start with mr lee please thank
you chairman i am matthew lee and i'm
lead specialist place here at malden
district council
thank you mr johnson are we here
i've got mr johnson on my list is he
here in fact
dude chairman i can't see his presence
no nor can i
um i've still got the wrong meeting chat
up
um
oh i see okay we're on a new chat that's
all right councillor fleming is
having problems i'll just make that note
right so we have no mr johnson
uh but we do actually have ms bowles so
if you could introduce yourself please
good afternoon i'm hannah bold and i'm a
specialist in development management
great thank you and berna
yeah found casey clark to this
afternoon's meeting thank you
thank you and i can see tara
tara is streaming the mission so she's
officially screaming the meeting not
taking part okay thank you are there any
other
officers oh mr johnson's here mr johnson
could you
introduce yourself my apologies michael
johnson
uh lead specialist development
management thank you
that's great thank you and uh
but are there any other officers who
were taking part in the meeting as
opposed to supporting the meeting
no no no no okay thank you
so berna could you carry out the wrong
call of members
to confirm who's in attendance thank you
chairman
i'll call your names in alphabetical
order starting with councillor bamford
councillor bamford sorry president
thank you brother thank you councillor
durham
present thank you councillor fleming
i i know she's present she's just having
problems connecting
some issues um okay
counselor um jarvis president thank you
tara
councilman council
uh president burner not tara carl
thank you how's this little um
mrs thompson's present counselor wright
president thank you thank you thank you
chairman can any other members
in attendance please introduce
themselves now
if we have any council
murray councillor morris is in
attendance anybody else in attendance
oh no i'm listening but i i won't be
participating because i'm busy but thank
you berna
thank you very much thank you chairman
okay thank you
um may i have apologies for absence
please berna
[Music]
can't hear you burner sorry
apologies chairman we've received
apologies for absence from councillors
keys and morally thank you
all right minutes of first of july
i'm here oh you made it thank you yeah
uh right can we note for the record that
council fleming has managed to reconnect
um minutes of the first july
um members can i take this as reg
those of you who were present then
does anyone need to go through the
meeting no agreed no
agree okay
can i agree those by general assent
please members
yes if anyone wishes to raise any
matters of accurate accuracy please
let me know now yeah
okay in that case i think berna we can
confirm that those are agreed
thank you right item four is
declarations of interest
i need to read this to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
peculiary interests other pecuniary
interests or non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda
having regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise through the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function now to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
i'm expecting something from councillor
uh okay i'm having trouble following the
chairman's chat
as well as the meeting chat so i'll
actually be grateful if people could
um indicate whether they wish to speak
on the meeting chat
if you could manage that that would be
terrific
counselor we'll start with you please
counsellor and then council sudan
yep thank you chairman uh
nonparticularly interested
member of essex county council who are
statutory consultees on planning matters
thank you
thank you councillor thank you chairman
uh yeah i'd like to declare a
non-pecuniary interest
on the summer house back lane
my mother lives on back lane obviously i
don't live with my mother
but however i feel it's significant
enough to declare a non-pecuniary
interest
i will not take part in the discussion
of that particular agenda item
and i won't vote on that item either
thank you
just to clarify for any members of the
public watching
you you will be remaining in the meeting
i'll stay in the meeting but yeah i'll
just yeah but i won't vote or take part
in any discussion
thank you that's just for clarity but
certainly it's easier than
actually leaving if you don't need to so
thank you for that
um is is that everyone a counselor
jarvis
oh sorry counselor jarvis yes thank you
i'd just like to disclose an interest
obviously a non-bikini interest i am a
parish councillor on wiccan bishops
parish council
regarding item five where that property
is
thank you okay i think we can now move
on to item
five which is the summer house battling
weekend bishops
um ms bowles is going to present so if
you'd like to go ahead with that
please do we do have three
three submissions received which i will
be asking an officer to read after we've
had the presentation thank you
ms foles thank you chad
planning permission is thought for the
erection of the dwelling
within the former garden area of the
summer house
the proposal seeks amendments to a
previously approved wedding which is
currently under construction at the site
we have the location plan
and the block plan
we have the proposed elevations
and the previously approved elevations
we've got the proposed floor plans
and the proposed roof plan
and the previously approved floor and
roof plans
and we've got the proposed street scene
elevation and the approved
street scene elevation
and then we've got some site photos
and some photos of the surrounding area
the proposed dwelling is located just
outside of the settlement boundary of
wiccan bishops where policies of
restraint apply
however the site benefits from an extent
permission which is
being lawfully implemented
and a dwelling is currently under
construction at the application site
therefore the principle of the proposal
was established
the amendments to the approved design
are considered to have an acceptable
impact on the character and appearance
of the area
they would not detrimentally impact the
immunity of the neighbouring occupiers
and adequate parking provision and
immunity space would continue to be
provided
therefore the application is recommended
for approval
thank you chair thank you
um mr lee who's going to read the
submissions is that you or mr
johnson or someone else
i haven't been provided with them so
it's not me
i don't know um because we decided to
move away from having a memory
yeah i don't recall that but i've not
been provided with them
just to add to that counselor i've i've
not been made aware of reading
out the submissions and i have noticed
that it doesn't seem to be the case with
all with all committees
as well it's uh sorry chairman it's not
standard across the piece it's up
down to the individual chairman uh i'm
happy to read them out if that's if that
suits the purpose
i think we had it so with clarity i
think we had agreed that it would be
offices i don't think we
decided how it was going to be but yeah
well then i didn't realize it wasn't
already organized
burner if you would be so kind um i'd be
very grateful thank you
no problem so the first submission
submission one is from david pearl
an objector this developer wants to
build a larger house than he currently
has permission for
the psycho began in 2013 when the
applicant sold permission to build a
house in his garden
this was refused by molten district
council as the land is outside the
settlement boundary
and would intrude into the countryside
malden district council's planning
officer judged it would be a blot on the
landscape
outline permission was however given on
appeal in 2014 as
mdc did not have a five-year housing
land supply in 2018
mdc approved detailed plans consistent
with the outline approval
and construction work reportedly started
this year this is the developer's third
attempt in the last six years to obtain
permission to substantially increase
the size of the dwelling with both a
larger footprint and increased height
molten district council would be
undermining its own ldp policies
and establish an unfortunate precedent
if it approved this enlargement now
in refusing the previous attempt the
planning officer concluded in her report
only two months ago
that these new plans would substantially
change the design and appearance of the
simplistic and symmetrical dwelling
the impact of the proposed garage is
exacerbated by its prominent position
along the north northern side elevation
of the approved dwelling
and went on to say that the scale of the
proposed edition cumulatively with the
sighting is considered to result in the
development which is substantially
different in terms of design
appearance and scale from the one which
has been approved nothing has changed
these plans are identical to those
considered two months ago and remain in
conflict with policies s8
s1 and s8 with an ldp now in place mdc
has the authority to ensure that
developers can no longer use
the tactic of getting permission for
something and coming back later to build
bigger
i urge you to refuse this application
the second submission is from ian
wardrop
representing the parish council views
the parish council provides the
following additional points to those in
its response state of the 22nd of june
members will have read the appeal
decision which granted development here
in 2014
attempting to introduce a larger and
different design to that approval wood
it is submitted be circumventing the
decision reached by the planning
inspector
and be contrary to con condition four of
the decision
power 20 and condition seven of the
appeal decision are also relevant
the plans did not provide then for a
garage the addition of a garage now
is to all intents and purposes and
extension to the original design
even though the dwelling has yet to be
built it is submitted that this is
contrary to the planning inspector's
decision and condition seven
and would be another example of
attempting to circumvent the planning
inspector's decision
the applicant claims in the das para 1.5
that the original application was for a
basic design
and now submits that the current
applications for a better design
the original application was approved on
appeal without the suggestion that a
better design would be submitted
subsequently
power 4.2 of the das refers to an
overall reduction of 20 square meters in
floor space in the main dwelling
but the overall footprint of the
proposed development has been
substantially increased
by the addition of the garage the
officer has referred to the planning
history and in particular the x-stand
permission being
a material consideration which weighs
heavily on the approval this time
with respect to the officer that does
not mean that other factors
including the apparent circumvention of
the planning inspector's decision
should not be giving given due weight
this application conflicts with a number
of the criteria set out in power 5.2.3
of the office's report
the parish council does not agree with
the final sentence of power 5.2.10
this application is for a substantially
larger development than that for which
approval was given on appeal
it would be overbearing on the plot it
is outside the developing
boundary members are urged to refuse it
the final submission submission three is
from jonathan brown the agent
the main purpose of this application is
to add a garage onto the approved
dwelling which is currently under
construction
in addition to minor fenestration
alterations we note that council
jarvis referred the application to
committee on the basis that the proposed
development looks far too large for the
plot
therefore we highlight the following to
hopefully allay any concerns in this
regard
one the site map at page 14 of the
committee report shows the
plot and dwelling sizes in the
surrounding area many larger dwellings
along back lane to the east and grange
road to the west comprise dwellings that
cover the entire width of their plot
two molten's design guide advises that a
suitable garden size for this type of
dwelling is 100 square meters
and the current proposal provides the
rear amenity space of 500 square meters
three the footprint of the outline
planning permission in 2013 was 170.5
square meters
which would potentially allow a total
floor space of at least
341 square meters round floor plus
upper floor in brackets for the current
proposal including the garage totals 334
square meters in floor space
therefore whilst the footprint is
slightly larger the floor space of the
overall scream is no larger than
originally permitted
five the overall buck print has been
increased by 30 square meters with the
addition of a garage
although we would also highlight that
the width of the dwelling has been
reduced by one meter
reducing scale at first floor level
which offsets the impact of the increase
in footprint
to a degree six whilst the number of
bedrooms has been increased to five the
dwelling is actually smaller than
previously approved and the extra
bedroom is simply a result of an amended
internal layout
finally comments are made relating to
the site history but in the applicant's
25 years of
ownership there has not been a single
breach of planning control and the
applicant priced himself on acting
properly and was integrity
a neighbor with the parish council
support challenged the district
council's decision-making process
at the high court thereby causing the
entirety of any historical complications
they now unfairly use this to imply that
this complicated history
should outweigh against the applicant
that concludes the submissions chair
thank you very very well done if i may
say um
look members the obvious thing to do is
go to councillor jarvis because he
called the application in and he is the
ward member who lives nearest
um but could i please ask miss boles to
just point out on
some of her slides whichever she thinks
appropriate what the differences are
i noticed there was one of the
elevations of one above the other
proposed above
the um extant commissions is that
possible
um yeah just bear with me thank you
i'd just like to be a little more sure
of what i'm looking at and hopefully i'm
helping other members at the same time
so on the um the main difference is the
additional
garage here
sorry sorry um
so that's the main difference is the
garage the window here has also
um been amended as you can see and then
the width has been reduced by a meter
and the height has been slightly
increased by
0.2 meters i believe that they are the
main
uh very the main changes the porch has
also been changed from a picture of
porch
to a flat roof porch so they're the main
differences
thank you thank you appreciate that
okay um no we do have an officer's
recommendation to
to approve sorry i can't watch too many
bits of papers at once
uh if there's a second for that we can
go on and debate the
officer's recommendation otherwise would
someone give me an alternative proposal
please
i'd like to put an alternative proposal
forward if there's no secondary
um you got in before any seconders so
please um let's have your proposal
council jones
my proposal would be to refuse it
okay can i elaborate on that
yes i'd like some reasons or at least an
indication of your reasons please and
then we know what we're discussing
yes i mean i think uh this is at least
the third attempt
that the developers had to put a much
larger property
uh in in on that site um we've seen
we've heard quite a lot about the
history
um and uh you know it was
determined that outline planning
commission was given back in 2014 the
permission has been given to build a
property on the site
and in that respect of course there is a
principle of development but
i noted the officers words when they
said that therefore
the principle of development has already
been granted but
we can't just assume that because
permission for a small property
relatively small property has been given
that that means
that the principle is established that
somebody can come back and build a much
bigger property
that doesn't that doesn't follow in my
way of thinking
i think when i've looked at sort of
ridge height design size
the property uh the garage and i still
think that it's a
substantial infill uh in a relatively
small space
and not in keeping with that particular
part of the village
um so my reasons for refusal are the
same
that this is sort of some of the reasons
that have just been mentioned by some of
the objectives i think some of those
points are well made
there is reference to a number of other
properties in the area
um getting permission but um i've looked
at those and i think the conditions are
quite different
um reference is made to i think little
hill and two grange road
other properties but in those particular
cases um
their previous permission expired and uh
more recently the council gave a lot of
weight to the fact that they had
previously been approved
and therefore it expired so it was they
were allowed to renew but then
the the new applications were identical
to the original applications
and i think in those particular
circumstances it's reasonable to give
good weight
but in this case we can't give good
weight because
this is a totally different application
uh reviewing the plans
to um the application that was approved
um previously this property has got an
approved plan in place
um um and it's it's different to those
other two cases
so coming back on a regular occasion
for either modification or for new
applications
essentially just is is another way of
trying to get around i think
agreements that have already been made
by the inspector
and that is there is a certain size of
property that suits this plot
and the inspector has been quite
particular about that
and i don't think whether it's through
modifications or artistic drawings
or regular submission of plans we should
be minded
um not to look at the absolute basics
this is against the ldp
and we should vote against him
right do we have a second of that please
i have councillor white's hand up but is
she
councillor white are you seconding or or
speaking because i always have a [ __ ]
tape sorry no it was actually um i
i i was going to put forward my reasons
for a country proposal but i'll let
somebody else second it and then we can
vote
right well then
we can debate at least um
councillor bamford would like to speak
would like to speak
please council banford
at this stage i'm really only very
secondary sorry chairman but when i go
into the chat function i can't get back
into this screen very quickly um
i wanted to ask a couple of questions um
with this application is this
application a new application
an extension or an amendment
i'm really not sure what we are being
asked to consider
that's one question and
my other question was um
about the inspectors um
comments regarding the garage
doesn't that have any bearing on this
because it seems to me
in the report that the inspector said
that
the garage was a particular point that
wasn't allowed so
what bearing does that have on our
decision on this please
thank you wait i'm going to come to mr
lee i know councillor durham who is the
code ward member is desperate to come in
but so far i haven't got a proposal
that's been seconded
so i need a second to please would that
be you counselor darryl
uh not at this stage chairman
well that leaves me with an interesting
constitutional
um crisis because we have proposals
to both approve and refuse and nobody's
seconding either of them
well okay i don't think you need a
second to move the officer's
recommendation
i don't think i do but i like to out of
politeness so if we if councillor jarvis
doesn't have a second or in the next
five seconds or so we're gonna go i'm
happy to
second councillor jarvis's uh proposal
but i want to
uh remain open-minded uh hearing the
remainder of the debate thank you
of course you do right so we have a
proposal on the table which is in fact
to refuse
um would you like to go ahead and speak
councillor jarvis has said
pretty much most of his cases obviously
can sum up i've got mr lee trying to say
something
i'd like i'd like to chairman if before
i say anything i'd like to hear mr uh
lee's response to councillor bamford's
questions please thank you
mr luke thank you chairman um this is a
brand new application as the officers
paul explains um
this isn't an amendment this isn't um
you know
an extension age wedding has been
commenced on site
um and the applicant which is well
within their gift
is submitted to amend that proposal in
the
oldest sense as in they've submitted a
new application for something slightly
different
which is very common as members will be
aware
in relation to a couple of points that
have been made it's important to note
that the
application that was allowed up here was
outlined in
nature and it was for a dwelling um
subsequently they look
so there and while there was a condition
imposed saying that they
any garage on that dwelling could not be
built under permitted development
it would not mean that in the future an
application couldn't come in and be
assessed
just that it removed that pd right there
was nothing in the off
in the inspect decision to my
understanding that would say that
there is a prejudice or presumption
against a garage or anything like that
in the future
um was also just to make the clarity is
that the
last application that officers refused
as the report explains
was a new or second set of reserve
matters
and it was considered that what they
were proposing was not in line
with what had been granted outlined that
doesn't mean that a different
application couldn't or shouldn't be
supported
all it means is that it was materially
different to what had been granted
outline and the
description and the parameters etcetera
of what fell into that
you've got remember that layout was
included in the outline which quite
often they aren't and obviously
more information we have at outline
stage less they can do at reserve
matters without
having to get additional permissions and
that's the situation we found ourselves
in is that the applicant wants something
that is materially different
to the previous application um but that
on its own is not a presumption against
development or reason for refusal
what the decision makers have to be is
to assess what could be built
or is being built today not even could
be is being built today
and what they're proposing different and
to see if there's any harm
and i know the chairman's already asked
that but we'll ask
the case officer ms bowles if she can
just take office
to take members through that because
council jarvis said that he considers
the changes to be quite extreme for one
of the better word
and um although they are materially
different officers don't
consider that so if ms bowles doesn't
mind if you could just take members
through the main points again just for
clarity that would be appreciated
thank you chairman thank you miss bowles
if you would
yeah thank you um so there has been
an increase in the ridge height um of
the maximum bridge height by 0.2 meters
um the garage is obviously the biggest
change
as you can see this is the previously
approved one um
the width of the main body of the
dwelling has been reduced by
one meter and so even with the
the garage the footprint of the dwelling
has only increased by 30 square meters
which
um isn't isn't a major increase
um there's been minor finish
fenestration changes
and as i pointed out earlier this this
window on the front elevation
and the the change to the porch as well
um and the internal change also
um obviously that that wouldn't require
pounding permission in its own right
to create a fifth bedroom and there were
the changes
uh thank you thank you
right who else who would like to speak
we have councillor dharam who wants to
speak but not until he's heard some
other views unless you're ready to come
in now
um your background is back to front
counsellor
is it that's true i think you took
mirror image
because you're from doddlam district
council there you go thank you here we
go
uh yeah thank you very much um yeah okay
i hear um everything that's been said um
i think i i can't agree with
with my co-work counsellor that the the
changes are significant
with it with the exception of the garage
um which
is considerably different obviously
being a garage and then
not being a garage um i i also weigh up
the uh the situation you know if
if there isn't a garage you're gonna
have more cars parked outside which
could be
um visually less appealing and various
bits of paraphernalia
um but i think i i think on balance
um that uh
that this should be that this should be
refused
and uh i'm more than happy now to
support um
the council jarvis's proposition
to refuse this you are
okay thanks thank you uh any other
member i have counsellor jarvis
uh who would like to come back and sum
up but um that presupposes that after
that's after everybody else council
white
[Music]
uh thank you ma'am chairman i mean i i
have to say that i
although i i don't necessarily like the
way the application has come before us
i just think that if it goes to appear
it's likely to be approved because i
don't think
it's significant enough to be refused
and although they had to put an
application in i think it's perfectly
acceptable to have a garage adjacent to
a house
so i have to say i think this
application should be
um approved because i think we'll lose
appeal if we refuse it
and i don't think it's i don't
understand the high feelings of the
neighbours but we are where we are and i
don't think a garage is a problem
thank you councillor bamford wants to
come back
thank you chairman um thank you mr lee
for explaining
um the points that i raised before
so i'm thinking if this is a new
application then we should be looking at
it as if it was a new application
and before the application was not
approved with the garage
and suddenly we've got a garage and
it makes it much bigger than was
originally agreed
so i think that
i agree with councillors durham and
jarvis
that we should not be approving this one
that it is against
um policies s1 and d1
and i know councillor durham has
seconded but i think those are the
reasons why
it should be refused thank you
council fleming please
thank you chairman um yeah i i actually
disagree with
councillors durham and jarvis i
i think the officers are right with
their recommendation i can't see
that the changes to the building are
different
i see that the garage is obviously
different
but um i think at appeal
i think possibly this would win um
so i just because you know
the house probably needs a garage thank
you
thank you um
right councillor jarvis if you'd like to
sum up oh counselor why are you coming
back or did you
forget to put your hand down
i put mine back up again chairman okay
council darren
please yeah um i i i think
um i forgot my train of thought now
um i i i'm just slightly concerned that
um
if we um
with the with the with the proposed
pending changes to pdrs
i think that it's not going to be long
before the uh
the developer just has to sit tight and
he'll be able to put the um
various bits and pieces he wants in
without even coming back to us but
uh um yeah um apart from that i
am going to stick by my original
discussion
because the the garage is a significant
bulk on the side of the
dwelling and councillor white's not
necessarily councillor white could you
possibly
mute please thank you
all right could we have yeah thank you
all hands down except people who
actually waiting to speak
but i'm going to come back to councillor
jarvis but i'm going to
give the warning that i definitely want
us to be tied down
absolutely on what our reasons are for
refusal before we go to a vote
and i'm going to ask mr lee first do you
have something you can work with are you
still waiting to hear something
that you can use mr lee
um
obviously verbalize
the summary of what the reason for
approval would be or why
would going against that also a
reasonable refusal but generally i've
heard um planning
points but after obviously council
jarvis has done that i'd like to come
back but yeah
right um because i will be asking us to
get the wording right and
hopefully for burner to put it on the
screen so we all know exactly what we're
doing
so councillor jarvis please let's come
back to you
thank you chairman um just to pick up on
uh councillor white's point i mean
i i think uh she was mentioning that
this one might go to appeal on the
inspectors i mean it's very difficult to
know what the inspectors
would obviously determine um the there
are sort of laws themselves
but actually i think if it did go this
way this one would lose so if that's a
consideration for people
um i think it's just worth noting that
i know the officers are sort of
suggesting that that it's not
not that different really to the to the
previous one but
when to only two months ago the
modification was put forward which was a
modification
officer's view then was that it would
substantially change the design
appearance of the simplistic symmetrical
dwelling
the impact of the bose garage is
exacerbated by its prominent position
along the northern side elevation of the
approved weighing
went on to say the scale of the proposed
edition cumulatively with the sitting is
considered to result in the development
which is substantially different in
terms of design appearance and scale
from the one that has been approved and
therefore
obviously is in conflict with policies
s1 and s8
now as as um officer lean
will know those were his own officers
comments about um
their view of what this modification was
to the previous application
so although we are now looking at a full
application a different application
surely those comments are still relevant
when we're trying to compare the
differences between what's currently
approved and what's before us now to be
approved so i would ask councillors to
bear in mind that those are the officers
comments uh only two months ago
and uh i think i'd just like to you know
again uh
chairman just recommend refusal and at
this point i think i've got councillor
durham as a seconder
i'd like to move to a vote thank you
i've just got one point of
clarification from mr lee he did say
and i'm reading it here that the
previous application that was refused
was matters and therefore necessarily
tied into the original position
permission whereas this is a new
application
and therefore the original
is far less relevant have i got that
right yeah thank you chairman
yeah you've probably signed up better
than i would have done yet that this
is a reserve that that was a reserve
matters that
assessment is in relation to the
information we had to outline and the
parameters that are laid out
outline and including layout and the
bulk of putting
there was a slight alteration in the
layout there's additionality to the side
etc and it was considered that in a
totality
that resulted in a different form of
development to what was within the
parameters of the outline
it's not saying that we would be not
accepting the development
and for that that is what this
conversation is about that's what this
application is about
that was assessing it as in is the
proposal basically the same as before
and there's no officers just report here
does and i've said and the
presenting officer has said nobody's
saying that it is the same
we have to assess though are the
differences so
severe as to warrant a refusal are the
changes in a 0.2 meter in height
reduction in the width of the oval
building but the additionality of a
garage at the side at single storey
are those changes so significant that
let's be honest it probably will end up
an appeal the inspector's going to look
at it
and say that this development offends
the character of the area that it causes
demonstrable harm
and my advice to members is that
officers will say that that is
you know the inspector is not going to
consider that thank you
last question are you clear on what we
are saying our reasons for refusal would
be
through chen i think i want a bit cloudy
because there does appear to be a lot of
basis on
the fact that this is different to what
was at the last application and that
isn't on its own a reason for refusal
right thank you so councillor jarvis and
or councillor durham um
or indeed anyone um it's back to you i'm
afraid i realize you you want to go to a
vote
i think we all do but we need to know
precisely what we're voting on
can i um just can i just add a comment
there
um yeah i've just just been having a
look at the um
the inspector's appeal and you know
there were discussion also about the
um the lack of a five-year housing land
supply at the time
but the inspector was quite clear in in
in his decision then that he
read that development in its particular
context
he acknowledged that it was outside of
the settlement however he felt that it
was
more to be read as part of the
continuation of a
of a line of of of properties and
therefore was to be logically read as
part of that settlement
so if we're you know sort of trying to
reinvent the wheel in terms of the whole
principle
i don't think that there's a significant
basis on which we can be considering any
refusal
on on that basis i just wanted to
support again
uh my colleague mr lee in terms of the
distinction between the officer's
refusal
of the last application and our
consideration of this application
it really is based on understanding the
differences between the type of
applications we deal with
the reserve matters can only be read and
only be considered in terms of the
general outline
a significant change to the outline that
that was approved
cannot be then subsequently you know
materially changed under reserve
matters and that's something that
members need to fully understand
um this application uh considered in
terms of the inspectors comments
of its appropriateness the reduction in
the
main building itself except for a 20
centimeter increase in height which is
barely noticeable on on a pitch roof at
30 square meters
in terms of uh the garage its
relationship to the boundary
and the nearest properties to all
intents and purposes mean that any
refusal
on that basis will be difficult to
defend thank you chairman
thank you i appreciate that right i've
got councillors
so why and one other with their hands up
sorry i know i said i use the hands but
can we go back to using the chat please
okay sorry thank you just
yeah just to say that again i don't
think 20 centimetres in height is a
problem they've actually made the house
smaller
and i think it will save the applicant
and the authority an awful lot of money
you know if we approve these
insignificant changes i mean admittedly
i understand there's local high feelings
over it
you know when you listen to the
gentleman's um objection
but i i just think i don't have a
problem with it garage with it with a
reasonable sized house no issue at all
thank you thank you i've got councillor
bamford we are looking for reasons to
thank you
councillor white i appreciate what
you're saying um but we are looking for
to
tie down the reasons for refusal so we
can vote because we do have this
proposal on the table and we need to
crack on with that councillor bamford
thank you chairman well i just think
that from what the officers have said
um we can't refuse it because they're
saying there are no reasons
however to me this is a brand new
application
and it's outside the development
boundary but
um you know the officer is saying we
can't use that as a
objection so i i think we're between a
rock and a half place here
well there is that we need to be under
some kind of uh
instruction that we can't object to it
blue chairs um
this is a new application that is right
but as members know
we have to determine a plan application
according to the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise there is a house being built
on this site
physically right now objecting to the
principle
would be a unbelievably dangerous route
to take
notwithstanding that mr johnson's
explained what the inspector said
at the time of the appeal and he found
no objection to the although it was
contrary to policy to the principle of
putting a drilling on this house because
how it'll be read in the street scene
so between those two points one of and a
specter was assessed to scheme and found
that
it's fine to have a house on this site
outline stage and that's
that's a material consideration that we
should be giving substantiate for
and the fact that they are building a
house on this side at the moment
there is no way in my professional
judgment that we should even consider
that
as and it's you know it's very rare for
me to go with extreme members
but i would advise you to not give any
thought to the idea of
going on principle because there is a
house being built and that is a material
situation of unbelievable weight in
determination this application
thank you chairman um
question for councillor job is really
are we going with
cyclone bulk i mean i need a definitive
reason for refusal i know i'm doing
pernici
but i don't want to end up with mr lee
and mr johnson and miss bowles going
away thinking
what they said wasn't clear because it's
not clear to me
gentlemen i've heard people comment on
the property one would think that the
new application was
of no greater size at all but it quite
clearly is uh a larger development
that's um
and this is the third attempt that the
applicant has had
to build a more substantial property so
um you know i sort of
rest my case and i think the i think as
far as the
property is concerned it will have a big
impact uh
it is garden development back garden
infill development
and um i think uh uh yeah the size of
the property
substantial size of it will have an
adverse appearance
uh on the on on the street and sort of
local properties
mr lee dude chairman um obviously
designers always
subjective point um but as i keep
saying there is not been a previous
application that we've considered as an
authority for this
proposal um the and to my knowledge i
have said this the third time i think
i'm correct it's the second time
and that was refused on the point of
principle of it going outside of the
reserve matters it wasn't a full
application
it wasn't what this application is for
more than it was because it was a point
of comparison
so using that as a material
consideration i advise should not be
what members do because you members all
know that i'll
highlight history and how the weight we
have to give it if that you know if the
council has whether it's office or
members
the way we should give that but that is
that previous application was only
reserved matters
and was fused of its conflict with the
outline
so that's that shouldn't really be given
any uh
weight and to reiterate what i just said
in relation to counselor bamford's point
cancer is almost raised again about
saying this is back land development
this is a scheme that an inspector who
says fine this is a scheme that a house
has been built on at the moment
that point all started by should not be
a material consideration in the
termination is application
if members consider an increasing height
of 0.2 of a meter
and an oval floor increase of
30 meters is so offensive to the street
scene that it warrants for his refusal
that's in their gift but i wouldn't be
advising that any of the other points
that have been raised are added to the
melting pot of consideration thank you
chairman thank you
so we're looking at that the increase in
ridge height of 20 centimeters which is
eight inches in old money
and the garage and the slight increase
in floor areas are reasons for refusal
are you
are you in agreement with that council
job is to adopt those as your reasons
for refusal yes thanks to
you okay thank you right we will go to a
vote then
so um werner could you please take the
vote
roll call based on councillor jarvis's
proposal to refuse based on the extra
height and floor area
of the property and
[Music]
or against storage stain okay thank you
thank you chairman i'll call you in
alphabetical order as normal
starting with counselor bamford four
durham
castle durham
council oh there he is cancer damn we
can't hear you
you're amazing you're muted
you can raise your hand for four
so that's four counts of john yes um
counselor fleming against
casa jarvis four
cancer civil abstain
oh thank you cancer yes of course cancer
thompson
against
okay so that's so that's three for the
refusal three abstentions
and one sorry three against and one
abstention
so um i'm going to cast and i'm gonna
cast
with the approval which with the
officer's recommendation
um which we do for completeness sake
have to go back and vote on but i am
going to ask against the
proposal to refuse so can we please now
revert to the officer's recommendation
and take a vote on that okay thank you
council banford for the office's
recommendation of approval
against castletown
can't hear you
against
did you get that burner four that's four
thank you councillor fleming
sorry councillor jarvis against
castle
was that me berna sorry you're
abstaining aren't you
i am yes sir thompson um
for the officer's recommendation
four so that's
three four three against
no abstentions oh now we have now we've
got two of them
it's abstaining
councils are unsustaining okay so bear
with me please
i didn't see that so that's actually
three four
two against one abstention
well two of them got councillor
no i happen to include a council siddill
he's not voting on this
okay we'll worry about that later i
think that does count as an abstention
but it doesn't affect
voting doesn't affect the voting okay so
well it's two abstentions so it's
three four two against two or three with
the officer's recommendation yes
so that's carried so that is carried
that
application is approved in line with the
officer's recommendation
thank you everyone all right moving on
uh land adjacent to the old wheat chief
the street
stone marines
all right moving to gender item six land
adjacent to the old wheat chief the
street stoma is found on pages 31-42
i will call in a moment on the officer
to present the item
a reminder if you wish to speak please
make this known using the chat
function and i will come to you in turn
um
we're actually with miss boles again for
this one
and um please continue
thank you chair planning permission with
all matters reserved is sought for the
construction of the new detached living
we have the location plan
and the block plan and
site photographs the proposed wedding is
located outside
of the settlement boundary of stone
marines where policies of restraint
apply
the construction of the dwelling would
have an unacceptable urbanizing effect
on the site and surrounding countryside
and there are no material planning
considerations
that would outweigh the conflict with
policy therefore the application is
recommended for refusal
thank you chair
thank you well we have sadly lost
counselor
durham so i think we're going to have to
exclude him from this one
um do we have we don't have anyone to um
any submissions do we burna
no chairman not on this one thank you
um so counselor
this is called then council miss white
or councillor
thank you thank you and could i just see
the um floor plan up again please and
also the i know where it is in real life
but i want to see the location
plan as well please because for some
reason my computer was playing up at the
time but it's okay again now
through utah there is no um indicative
floor or elevation plans it is
simply the indicative location on the
block plan
thank you
thank you officers i want this to come
to committee because initially i didn't
have too much of a problem with it
and but i think the fact that all we
have is a square on the
piece of paper that we have to go with
the officer's recommendation much as
i've surprised myself and it's
the opposite to um to what i was
expecting to say
and i just think this application does
not have enough information for us to
determine it and therefore i agree with
your recommendation
thank you um does that mean i didn't
actually put the officers recommendation
yet so will you
would you be so kind just a second that
then we've got we can go on and debate
that's right
yeah i'm happy to second that thank you
very much any other member wishing to
speak
councillor fleming you are the other
ward member can you hear us okay
thank you chair um yes i think that on
balance i agree with the
officer's recommendation there are no
material considerations that our way
that's all i have to say thank you thank
you um
any other member wish to speak
especially if they have the
contra review
okay in that case i'm going to go to a
vote
um so we are taking a vote on the
officer's
recommendation to refuse with all the
reasons as outlined in the report
so berna could you please take the roll
call
yes chairman and just to say that cancer
jam had left the meeting but he was
intending to rejoin
but at the moment he still hasn't
rejoined so well
he was but unfortunately he won't be
able to vote because he missed the
presentation
exactly i just wanted to highlight that
yes thank you i appreciate that
i can see that he went um but
unfortunately we would have to exclude
him
if he does manage to get back just
asking in the lobby
so i'll admit him but i won't include
him in the voting
no i'll just explain that i'm sorry
councillor durham the um
yeah can you hear me now the
presentation i'm afraid so
um we can't include you in voting i'm
afraid it was a very short presentation
and you didn't quite make it back in
time
so we are can you hear me can you hear
me chairman
oh you can okay that's fine i will just
listen to the debate with interest thank
you thank you well
you've missed that okay so i just
well we are just about to take a vote on
the officer's recommendation
uh which was duly seconded and no one
has actually made any comments against
it so berna
thank you very much i'll call you in
alphabetical order four against abstain
counselor bamford
candice is the officers officer's
recommendation yes
for caster fleming
for mr jarvis
four
apart from the officer's reasons i think
basically to say that there's not enough
information to determine it in my
opinion
so thank you thank you
thank you thank you chairman we didn't
introduce any extra reasons for the
refusal and it's the nature of outline
permissions that we don't know anything
about them which is
why neither members nor officers are
that keen
however thank you for that we have in
fact refused that application
on the grounds and reasons for refusal
based in
in the offices offices report
um item seven is any other items of
business the chairman of committee
decides are urgent and there are none
so members i'm going to close the
meeting with thanks to all members all
officers and everyone who supported us
which is you know a whole bunch of other
officers i draw this meeting to a close
at my machine says 1358
so thank you